in the history of eSports certain
highlights have managed to transcend
games plays so incredible that no fan
regardless of game loyalty can deny
their brilliance think of dota twos the
play jumping in CS and League of Legends
the expec a however before any others is
one that stands alone a play which is
arguably the original iconic eSports
moment and is quite possibly the most
influential of them all Evo moment 37
[Applause]
by 2004 Daigo Umehara and justin wong
were titans of street fighter you know
everybody was trying to beat a lot of
fighting game to keep us not fighting
him because of he just the greatest of
all time in one corner you had the beast
Daigo the Japanese champion known for
his skill discipline and iron resolve
Daigo was feared and respected in the
West since his Street Fighter Alpha 3
win over Alex by a in 1998 he wasn't
caught off guard by anything and he just
had you know risks at the right time and
strategy that was too good to be in the
opposite corner the american justin wong
whose meteoric rise was propelled by his
prodigious talent across multiple games
he was so good at so many games and
there regardless of what game he wanted
to play if he took venice time.i he
would have been amazing at it
the two were fated to meet and it
finally happened in the losers final of
Street Fighter 3rd strike at Evo 2004 it
was dai goes Ken versus Justin's chun-li
a classic Street Fighter 3 matchup that
both players knew inside and out while
the match was expected to be exciting
not even Justin and I go could have
known it would change the course of
fighting game history forever the match
started intensely
[Applause]
with both players earning themselves
around a piece the first game came down
to a deciding round three Justin took a
commanding lead
one strike away from defeat Justin
throughout chun-li's who you who sends
super a 15 strike attack he figured
Daigo would drop an input gambling that
the beast wouldn't be perfect for just
one split second he was wrong
[Applause]
the Daigo Perry is unbelievable because
any of the hits
even if blocked would have been enough
to knock die go out and give Justin the
first game Daigo had to perfectly time
his Perry's for all 15 strikes which
requires nearly frame perfect inputs
on top of doing just that he ended the
fight with his own super sealing one of
the flashiest
and most unbelievable comebacks of all
time you know everyone kept talking
about how great he is and everything
like that but the Daigo Perry was that
one moment where it happened and it
happened in front of a bunch of people
and it was ridiculous it's just like
when someone like Kobe or Michael Jordan
hits that game-winning shot like you
hear about how great they are and then
you see them do it and you're at the
live game and you're just like this is
the greatest thing in the world in many
ways evil moment 37 is the most famous
eSports highlight there is it inspired a
generation of fighting game fans and
would-be pros alike its importance in
the landscape of the fighting game
community simply cannot be overstated
thirteen years later the clips still
receives tributes in various forms of
media drawing parallels between it and
iconic sporting moments while Justin and
Daigo have amassed incredible careers
and have faced off in numerable times
since evo 2004
their rivalry always comes back to Evo
moment 37 on the 10-year anniversary of
the play they even recreated a highlight
reel he got the jump off door here it is
why'd I go once again nailed the parry
this time Justin won the round for its
legacy its significance and for the play
itself the word iconic is the least you
can say to describe evil moment 37 it is
the spirit of the fgc perfectly captured
in pixels poetry and devastating motion
and history heard in the roar of a crowd
that knew they were witnessing the
impossible made into reality
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]